[Music]
hi and welcome we're here at the
security zone annexed with Lorena
Crowley a fishing expert at Google cloud
how you think happy to be here so
phishing attacks are an increasingly
difficult threat for security teams to
deal with these days right
and one of the most common attack
vectors that phishing attackers use to
trick users is phishing websites Wow can
you explain how and why attackers create
these phishing websites phishing
attackers create sites that are designed
to trick employees into clicking on a
link downloading a file or providing
sensitive information these phishing
websites look like legitimate websites
so it's very difficult for employees to
spot them and attackers are creating
millions of these websites and putting
them all over the web to try and trick
users so that means employees across all
sorts of companies are clicking on these
links to the sites and accidentally
finding them while browsing and what
happens then when an employee opens up
these sites well let's take a look at
some web sites and see it from an
employee's point of view so let's say
you're browsing the web and open some
sites from your emails and you come
across these web sites let's see if you
can spot which ones are legitimate and
which sites are actually phishing
websites okay I'll give it a shot well
this one looks like a financial website
so I think well the URL looks good I'm
gonna say this is a safe site correct
nice work that is a legitimate web site
let's try another all right again and
well this just looks like the Gmail
login and it seems reasonable see that
pretty often
oh no that's actually a phishing website
it's hard to spot some of these yeah so
what happens then when I fall for one of
these phishing sites well in this
example you may have given away some of
your credential details
but the site could have also tricked you
into providing other information that's
important like company data or other
sensitive info attackers are constantly
creating more of these phishing sites
and they're getting more sophisticated
and difficult for users to spot in fact
the recent report estimated that 1.4
million of these phishing sites are
created every month Wow
so employees are just going to be
increasingly coming across these
websites by accident and be a targeted
attacks right but luckily there are some
tools for companies to protect employees
from phishing website attacks one of
those main tools companies can use is
safe browsing your Chrome browser Google
is constantly scanning the web and
identifying malicious phishing websites
these phishing websites are then stored
in a blacklist on Google servers this
blacklist then gets synced with Chrome
browser so when an employee opens a
malicious phishing website the website
is automatically blocked and the user
sees this morning right so even if an
employee opens up one of these web sites
chrome can detect it and alert them
before they open up the web site exactly
Chrome browser stops these employees
from accidentally putting sensitive data
into the hands of attackers that's
really great and so how does this work
with Google clouds other phishing
protection tools that's a great question
protecting against phishing website
attacks is only one part of a phishing
protection strategy tools like Chrome
browser works seamlessly with Gmail for
email phishing protection and security
keys for strong two-factor
authentication to write companies with
end-to-end phishing protection
well Lorena thanks so much for walking
us through Google cloud and protect
employees from phishing attacks it's my
pleasure
[Music]
you